hi i'm queenie i'm olivia i'm ilana i'm
lillian hey
i'm kylie and we're boys and we're here
today with buzzfeed to play a game of
who's who
who's most likely to forget choreography
okay okay see the thing is
i haven't had any dance experience you
know before the group
i got here could have been it's too late
string noodle
you're so much tired thank you guys yeah
and even if you forget i don't care
so it would yeah yeah i'll keep going
who's most likely to nail choreography
the fastest
oh we got everywhere i said you only
because i feel like you remember things
so fast yeah i feel like i do
i said you because when we're doing tic
tac dances you always know the next step
and i have to look for you
oh okay who's most likely to laugh at
inappropriate times
both of these both
like we will laugh forever it's so bad
yeah it is
but it's hilarious who's most likely to
not respond
in the group chat oh we're doing lana
okay
well you just i mean you two sometimes i
feel like but just tell me why i'm
swiping up
she swipes swipes yeah i've seen her
multiple times
just let it go okay i'm not even gonna
try to make up an excuse i don't know
what it is sometimes i just can't in the
moment i'm just like i can't yeah you
can't hey that's horrible but
i'm not gonna make an excuse for myself
who is the best at doing impressions of
the other bandmates
i don't know well i thought olivia does
impressions all the time but they're not
the best
oh okay myself i say
lily i'd say you because you do it's
just funny i think i just
go for it if someone asks go for it
right
we're gonna do well how about we guess
who you're doing all right let's get
let's
guess who you are yes okay okay i think
i have to stand up for this oh my god
let's get a position oh she's stepping
out
into the hallway
emily kylie
who's most likely to be caught napping
in between
let's say everything okay
she will nap at any time that's one
thing
i admire it like we'll have a meeting
and she'll be like i'm a nap
and i'm like it's 3pm i'm so confused
we have a compilation of her vaping and
pictures of her sleeping like with the
with the
what was it called a really soft and it
was a great pop
in her mouth all right guys who is most
likely
to be cop taking a selfie no questions
asked
oh wait miss leo what do i say to that
like
sometimes you need them stored in your
phone right content
you gotta show your future kids some
pics of you who's most likely to
brighten your day
[Music]
right in your freaking day why are you
saying those colors
no because you might really thank you
i take pride in it and it's a lot to
carry on my back
trying to be funny funny funny but
sometimes you just got to do it
who's most likely to be the first one
ready for the day
i think i take the shortest amount of
time oh yeah
but she didn't know yeah you know what i
mean
she's punctual you're quick who's most
likely to be the last one ready for the
day
those joke right there i think we know
because we're both scramblers
i actually have to get in behind her in
the car so she has to move the scene
yeah and i have to crawl through a
little crevice so it works out though
because i'm not always just like waiting
yeah
like like going in the car
but i actually wake up the same time as
her i'm up the earliest
but i'm still one of the last yeah yeah
and i just have the issue of just
forgetting and
not remembering that's the same thing
yeah
who's most likely to be the next faction
icon
for all of us everybody hello
no i feel like we're all so distinct
with our like our styles and outfits so
i feel like
we can all be so powerful and whatever
aesthetic we fit
i would say i'm very sporty street style
but i do love my classy side
i would say i'm a grandma's couch
possibly in the 80s
or 70s like i stripped in this room yeah
it says world's greatest mom i don't
have a child
i love the sweater i would say mine is
very feminine
classy and i do love street style too so
it's like a
mix of both i am
more the grunge edgy dark i like
layering i like baggy all that type of
stuff
and i am
i'm like the little kid who never grows
up i'm like peter pan
kid core my fashion inspo icon will be
harper from wizards of waverly place
who is most likely to cook dinner for
everyone else
you you'll be
[Music]
i don't cook because everyone will be
sick if i do oh my gosh
who's most likely to postmates breakfast
lunch and dinner
i do cook but i do love to send it on
food
it's a problem i've had to delete my
postmates
who's most likely to start the next
tick tock dance trend and i know you
tried
yeah i did drive she really tried and i
gave her that yeah yeah i think just
me because i would just do something
weird and then catch on but i think you
because you would like make a routine
like put it together yes
yeah okay who's most likely to be
secretly
lip-syncing under their face mask oh
i'll say all of them i'll be singing out
loud in the store
yeah i don't realize it we'll be walking
down the island yeah
it's not even harmonizing when we're
walking together like it's totally
bothering you don't even
who's most likely to write the next
boy's world head
yeah on the same page yeah we on the
same page because i do feel like
they've actually pitched songs to us and
so i feel like they're working on their
craft on yeah
making a boys world song so i thought
that's why we're saying that
so don't be surprised if you see one an
album one day
i'm gonna crying
my writing inspirations are phineas i
love julia michaels justin tranter
max martin and salvador i've been
reading about them for like years and
years i aspire to be like
like a woman max martin one day make all
that pop all those hot pop records
i wanna do it so bad thank you so much
buzzfeed for having us
and check out our new ep
you